[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
une légende raconte qu'il y à environ
300 milles en 2 real et tout premiers
êtres humains pour les employés comme
serviteurs dans le royaume des dieux
[Musique]
grand et robuste tes ancêtres de
l'espèce humaine avait eu tête quatre
bras 4 jean et deux organes cette peine
certains étaient dotés de deux textes
masculin d'autres de deux sectes féminin
et d'autres encore d'un sexe masculin et
d'un sexe féminin
[Musique]
mais ces créatures étaient très
insolente au lieu de servir les lieux
elle voulait les remplacer et prendre le
pouvoir
et mine de ne rien voir il avait besoin
de main d'oeuvre pour les travaux qu
aucun dieu ne voulait faire il pensait
même que ses serviteurs étaient trop peu
nombreux et qu'ils auraient dû en créer
d'autres plus calmes
tout se passait donc plutôt mal que bien
entre les dieux et les êtres humains
quand un jour ces derniers en chis la
limite de l'arrogance il insulte the sea
lourdement que celui ci
pris de colère lester ce dit un parent
et l'étrange en deux à coup de foudre
[Musique]
depuis vivant en équilibre précaire
les deux moitiés du même corps se
cherche désespérément pour se réunir
certains hommes cherchent des hommes car
leur corps original avait deux sectes
masculin certaines femmes cherchent des
femmes car leur corps avait deux textes
féminin et certains autres hommes et
femmes se cherche d'entre eux car leur
corps original avait les deux sexes
des créatures primitives ne connaissait
pas le rapport sexuel ne sachant pas
comment reconstituer leur corps
originale les deux moitiés ne faisait
que s'embrasser
étourdi par la joie des retrouvailles il
ne mangeait même plus par crainte de se
séparer
ils mourraient de faim
alors faisons est qu'ils ne souhaitaient
pas l'extinction de ces serviteurs mais
plutôt leur démultiplication charge le
dieu et rust de leur enseigner comment
se réintégrer dans un seul corps afin de
se multiplier sans endommager
[Musique]
inutile de dire que et ross
dieu de l'amour accompli bien sa tâche
la rendant même très agréable si
agréable que dès lors reproduction ou
pas aucun homme ou femme quelle que soit
son orientation sexuelle ne put se
passer de ce plaisir
[Musique]
enfin devenu reconnais ce temps les
êtres humains n'eurent plus aucune
animosité contre les dieux et leuze fut
satisfait il avait multiplié le nombre
de ses serviteurs et les avait même
calme et permettant dans sa bonté divine
qu'il jouisse d'intervalle relaxant
entre les d'innombrables tâches qu'ils
n'allaient leur préparer
[Musique]